i'm about to take this victory lap huh
no
fresh out the car oh that was the one
we're about to test drive this beautiful
volkswagen passat
got a little powerful feel the grill i
saw was pretty mean so
it was dope well let's get it man let's
get up in here let's go
[Music]
tell me a little bit about what
motivates you at the core it's never
like really being like satisfied you
know like you always want more and you
want it now
but i'm in year two right now i'm not
supposed to be
accomplishing everything that you're 15
guys accomplished already sometimes you
got to slow yourself down a little bit
you know
you're on pace though you're trying man
you had a good pace
let's talk about a specific time where
you really had to step
up to be honest the most recent one was
like last year
in philly coming in i was not really on
the roster whatever but you know we had
a couple injuries and whatnot and like
you know you kind of get thrown in the
fire and
take the opportunity or you don't know
this is like what i've dreamed of and
where i wanted to be and i wanted to
take advantage of that so i think
something that people don't know about
you talk to me a little bit about that
man
the biggest one is probably that i like
to cook like
i feel like i'm a pretty good cook like
a lot when you want to impress a
specific young lady you
want to just say who but what is that
dish that you're going to make
i would do like a mediterranean like
lamb chop season them up a rice peel off
keep it real simple
how's it drive how's it feel feels good
man cause i love cars like that's kind
of oh where that's your thing i love
cars here i love cars
tell me about the chart give it a little
a little punch a little bit there you go
definitely does have a little something
under the hood there so it feels sleek
and like even on the outside
the rims are a little sportier room in
the back yes all that whatever
people that want to ride teammates
teammates friends kids
celebrity crushes celebrity crushes
you ready for this challenge that we got
coming up for you i'm always ready man
you all you're right i like that you
stay registered
stay ready so you don't gotta get ready
you don't gotta get ready
you're gonna drive through each cone you
come to the finish line you park the car
take the basketball power dribble
straight to the free throw rack make the
shot you dribble the other ball to the
three-point run
you make a shot from three times stops
if you beat the 90 seconds
you get to take a victory lap but if you
don't i get to take the victory lap
and you gotta pick up every cone from
the track
because i want to drive the car anyway
sorry i'm not going to let you over in
my account three
two one and go i'm out
let's go turn tight tight here
whips i hate none of them nope hey
does handle really well though glass
cones yeah
man i'm about to take this victory lap
huh no i don't know
[Music]
no time to waste get it ah
[Music]
fresh out the car oh
keep going
oh there she go first shot 105
105 let's go let's go how did it feel
going through the cone it was a lot of
fun cars fast faster than i expected
handles really well that was probably
the best part of the best part that's
the best part for sure
i get the video take that victory lap
man put your seatbelt on man leave me
here in the dust man i guess i got to
pick up the car you're picking up your
cars i'll pick up the cones
you came you conquered look he's still
whipping through look at him today was a
good day
got the dub so i better get ready to
pick up these cones man
man i got a lot more to go you should
come help